hey guys my name is Jess module it is
the 11th of September today and you're
watching games but news in things that
are weird a massive landmark in the
third person shooter genre may be
adopting an RTS format and on the Kinect
no less Gears of War tactics may be a
thing and the first gameplay clip from
the rather unexpected title has emerged
video links obtained the two-minute
video which utilizes Microsoft Kinect
camera to let players direct their
troops and call in airstrikes
mechanically it seems you'll be using
your finger to draw through the air to
pass instructions to your video game
soldiers in 2012 epic games canceled the
difference connect power title called
Gears of War exile but it's not clear
whether this and tactics are one in the
same or simply the result of somebody on
Epic Games staff who's super into the
Kinect if you're into things that go
bump in the night and you prefer those
things to be murderous aliens then you
may be interested in the PC requirements
for alien isolation UK dev Creative
Assembly has officially released the
system requirements and here's the bit
where you tell me if your PC is going to
measure up at the bare minimum the game
will need 4 gigabytes of RAM a dual core
cpu pushing 3.2 gigahertz a 1 gigabyte
graphics card at a baseline level and 35
gigabytes of hard drive space the
recommended settings are beefed up quite
a bit more over those basic ones and you
can check out those details in our story
on site also we have a metric ton of
sweet screenshots feed of you at your
leisure a new metal gear solid 5 fans
and pain video has come into our lives
and it features the meat assassin quiet
the tiny teaser was broadcast during a
special kajima station video by Kojima
himself and features one of the
principal female characters who
seriously needs to invest in some new
pants or a shut responding to fans upset
about the super short length of the
video Hideo Kojima inside that more will
be revealed at Tokyo Game Show which
takes place next week gamespot will be
bringing you coverage from the show so
make sure to stay tuned as for your
question of the day let me know what you
think of quiet and what you
want to see next from metal gear solid 5
if you're often more news you can head
to our site to check out stories on GTA
5 and the full super smash brothers
roster those are all the things that I
want to tell you about today be sure to
pop back same time tomorrow where i'll
give you my five favorite stories of the
whole gaming week i hope to see you then